♪
>> Tucker: A PROFESSOR AT
PRINCETON HAS JUST
DISCOVERED THE LIMITS OF
ACADEMIC FREEDOM, THE
FRAGILE FEELINGS OF
STUDENTS.
AS PART OF A LESSON ON FREE
SPEECH IN ANTHROPOLOGY CLASS
THE PROFESSOR CALLED BORIS
ROSEN ASKED STUDENTS WHETHER
IT WAS WORSE FOR A WHITE MAN
TO PHYSICALLY ATTACK A BLACK
MAN OR TO USE A RACIAL SLUR.
STUDENTS DIDN'T REACT WELL.
MANY STORMED OUT.
AT LEAST ONE GOT IN HIS FACE
AND SCREAMED THE F WORD.
ROSEN HAS CANCELLED HIS
CLASS.
BRIT HUME WENT TO COLLEGE
WHEN IT WAS DIFFERENT JOINS
US NOW.
[LAUGHTER]
SO, BRIT.
>> IT'S BEEN A WHILE THOUGH.
DON'T ASK ME HOW LONG IT'S
BEEN.
>> Tucker: I WON'T.
BUT, WHAT I FOUND SO
STRIKING ABOUT THIS ONE,
THIS CLASS -- THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING HE THREW OUT
THERE.
THIS CLASS WAS ABOUT SPEECH,
WHAT SPEECH IS OFFER.
IT WAS ANTHROPOLOGY CLASS.
HOW ODD IS IT THAT PRINCETON
STUDENTS COULDN'T HANDLE IT?
>> WELL, WE'RE TALKING HERE
ABOUT THE N WORD, WHICH IS
ONE OF THE UGLIEST WORDS IN
THE LANGUAGE.
>> Tucker: FOR SURE.
>> WE DON'T GO AROUND USING
IT FOR THAT REASON AND IT'S
OFFENSIVE.
HOWEVER, I WOULD SUBMIT
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN USING THE WORD AND
MENTIONING THE WORD.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN USING THE WORD THAT
IS TO SAY CALLING SOMEONE
THAT OR SPEAKING OF OTHERS
AND USING THAT WORD SAYING
THAT THEY ARE, YOU KNOW,
THAT.
AND MENTIONING AND
DISCUSSING THE WORD.
AND IN A CLASS DEVOTED TO
THIS VERY SUBJECT OF
LANGUAGE AND WHAT'S
OFFENSIVE AND WHAT'S NOT,
YOU OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
MENTION THE WORD AND IN SO
DOING SAY THE WORD.
AFTER ALL THE PROFESSOR
WASN'T CALLING ANYBODY BY
THAT NAME.
HE WAS SIMPLY DISCUSSING THE
WORD ITSELF.
AND THAT'S A DISTINCTION
THAT SEEMS TO ME HAS BEEN
LOST IN THIS ABSOLUTE WAVE
OF POLITICAL CORRECTNESS IN
WHICH SOME THINGS ARE SIMPLY
NOW UNSAYABLE.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> TO ME IT MAKES NO SENSE.
>> Tucker: LIKE MOST PEOPLE
I HATE THAT WORD AND I DON'T
WANT TO HEAR IT I ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO THINK THAT PRINCETON
STUDENTS WOULD BE RATIONALE
ENOUGH TO SAY WE ARE HAVING
A SPEECH VIOLENCE.
IS SPEECH EVER VIOLENCE THIS
IS A HORRIBLE THING AND HERE
IS WHAT IT IS.
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO TRACK
THAT BE SMART ENOUGH TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING BUT IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE THEY WERE.
>> NO.
I THINK ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
HERE, TUCKER, IS THAT, YOU
KNOW, AMERICA IS A
COMPASSIONATE COUNTRY AND A
COUNTRY THAT STRIVES FOR
JUSTICE AND EQUALITY AND WE
WANT TO BE SENSITIVE TO
OTHER PEOPLE'S FEELINGS.
AND, THEREFORE, IF YOU'RE A
VICTIM IN ANY OF THESE
AREAS, IT'S KIND OF A GOOD
DEAL.
YOU GET A LOT OF
CONSIDERATION.
YOU GET A LOT OF SYMPATHY.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT WE
HAVE REACHED A STAGE IN
AMERICA WHERE WE HAVE PEOPLE
BASICALLY GOING AROUND
APPLYING FOR VICTIM STATUS
OR SEEKING TO BE OFFENDED SO
THEY CAN REACT TO IT AND BE
INDIGNANT AND EVEN YELL F
BOMBS AT COLLEGE PROFESSORS.
AND I SENSE THAT IT'S
UTTERLY REGRETTABLE.
YOU SEE THIS SENSITIVITY
GOING ON ALL THE TIME.
WE TALK ABOUT SNOWFLAKES.
OUR COLLEAGUE FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR GUY BENSON RAN
INTO RESISTANCE UP AT BROWN
UNIVERSITY AND IVY WHERE
PEOPLE SAID IT WAS OFFENSIVE
AND WRONG FOR HIM TO BE
PERMITTED TO SPEAK THERE.
THIS ALL SPARTAN PART OF THE
SAME PHENOMENON.
WIDESPREAD AND WIDELY
REPORTED ON.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE IN
AMERICA DISPROVE OF THIS AND
YET ON IT GOES.
THE RESPONSIBILITY FALLS
UPON UNIVERSITY
ADMINISTRATORS AND THE
FACULTY WHICH PUT UP WITH
THIS CRAP AND HAVE FOR A
LONG TIME.
AND THIS NEEDS TO STOP.
>> Tucker: IN THE LETTER AT
BROWN THEY ACCUSE GUY BENSON
PROBABLY THE NICEST GUY IN
THE BUILDING ENABLING WHITE
SUPREMACY.
IF YOU HAD AN 18-YEAR-OLD
RIGHT NOW WOULD YOU BE
WORRIED ABOUT SENDING THAT
CHILD TO COLLEGE?
>> WELL, I HAVE AN
18-YEAR-OLD GRAND DAUGHTER
WHO IS AT COLLEGE.
AND I'M PLEASED TO SAY THAT
THERE HASN'T BEEN MANY
REPORTS AT THE COLLEGE WHERE
SHE IS GOING OF THIS KIND OF
STUFF GOING ON.
BUT IT VERY MUCH CONCERNS ME
AND, YEAH, I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT IT AND I GOT ANOTHER
GRANDDAUGHTER COMING ALONG
IN A COUPLE YEARS HEADING
OFF TO COLLEGE AND I VERY
MUCH HOPE THAT SHE'LL CHOOSE
A COLLEGE AND WILL BE ABLE
TO GET INTO A COLLEGE WHERE
THERE IS A MINIMUM OF THIS
KIND OF STUFF GOING ON.
MORE THAN THAT, TUCKER, I
HOPE BY THIS TIME THAT THAT
ATTITUDES ABOUT THIS WILL
CHANGE AND THESE COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS WILL BEGIN TO
GROW SOME BACKBONE.
>> Tucker: I HOPE.